Richard Brookhiser with all that color
on this morning what are you reading
what am I reading I am reading the
stories on on the the House of
Representatives signing a letter
protesting president's policies on
Bosnia and all the things you when you
pick up the papers this morning why did
this get your attention well on the
Washington Times it gets your attention
because you have this picture of a flag
being stepped upon and then it says 184
congressmen urge President to cancel
mission then in the New York Times which
buried it in the middle but they say it
was 201 members including 15 Democrats
had signed the letter which said simply
we urge you mr. Clinton not to send
ground troops to Bosnia Christopher
Hitchens I you came into this room
saying he saw the same thing the same
photo I was interested the same
photograph because I was wondering if
the Washington Times hadn't um violated
the provisions of the flag burning
amendment that I think it otherwise
editorially favors there's a an outright
desecration right on the front page of
our little conservative right I think I
have certainly hope the way the
amendment passes it won't be lawful to
show pictures of the American flag being
blaspheme din that back you can put it
in air quotes can't they these are
foreigners I said these are dirty
foreign registered ironic but I also
notice as Richard I think did that in
one of the pictures of the desecration
you can see somebody wearing a Redskins
hat some angle that's the Washington
Post on page one infuriated serving
there's no other front the person still
I think the times won some infuriated
Sir work whereas it endowment thrashing
Old Glory and not Washington Redskins
Washington Post there it is let's tell
the audience and we got that up I mean
this is not a color photograph doesn't
have the same impact as it no and this
is on the front page of the Washington
Post a Bosnian Serb soldier holds up a
torn American flag during a
demonstration by several thousand Serb
residents where's the [ __ ] fronts
right here they are how about that how
does that mean that what does it mean
what's interesting choice of from he
knows both hometown reporting as well
because the Washington Times
missed the possibility of fur well he
must die he must have bound the guy who
photographed the other picture for the
Washington Times presumably before we
move on to let me ask the two of you
what what is mm if you're a conservative
here pure liberal what's the position
you're gonna take in a situation like
this
Bosnian the whole issue and it doesn't
split on conservative liberal does it no
it doesn't know I've I wish that the
international community didn't read in a
long time before now in Bosnia and I
found that on the whole people on the
Left which is where I start from we're
not as keen as I was and there were some
very bizarre people on the right who
were making the I think bizarre who are
sort of making the running actually
principally Baroness Thatcher would say
look there's no there's no reason to
total it soaps keep on doing this and
this is great it ought to be stopped so
you're for enter vania well I'm not very
much I'm not very strongly in favor of
the Dayton Agreement which i think is a
bit of a sellout I mean but I think the
Bosnian presidency is right in saying
that it is not justice but it is perhaps
peace and peace is better than nothing
mr. Brookhiser were you well we a
National Review has been calling for
years that that the Bosnian but the
Moslems be trained that they be allowed
to arm themselves but we we don't like
the Dayton Agreement it seems to be
putting the United States in the role of
enforcing a peace which nobody on the
ground really likes they they like it
only because they're exhausted or
they're temporarily exhausted and and
and people have lost sight of the notion
of a limited national interest I mean we
have a real national interest in
stopping aggression in Europe but since
the Serbs are not animated by any
hostile superpower or by any hostile
ideology our interest is a limited one
and if there are people on the ground as
there are who are willing to fight this
we should help them and let them do it
here's the cover of a new book coming
out founding father George Washington
rediscovering what would he think of
this whole
move to Bosnia well we did look at the
book is not my book is February 22nd by
the way is when it's coming out easy day
easy date to remember and the point of
the book is not to say to look at 200
year old policy prescriptions and say
what he would think now the point of the
book is to ask why is this man famous
but it may not be the point but I want
to ask how you want anything what would
he think well he he was against habitual
alliances with foreign powers he said if
you have an ongoing alliance you are a
slave to that to that friendliness with
another country which is not not
pertinent in this case because we don't
have any historical alliance or
antipathy with any of the sighs mr.
Hitchens this book which you wrote with
mother Teresa on the cover but first of
all I thought it might Bend Mother
Teresa's book that's out what would she
think of this whole she would not be I
think under that impression she does
have a book out of her own or least it's
been ghost written for her it's called a
simple path I think the only fair thing
to recommend is that you go to your
nearest fine bookstore and order both of
them the contrast will be will be
instantly
I think available to you what else did
the two of you reading this morning we
have the Washington Post page one had a
story on the vote to ban partial birth
abortions and Senate yeah this morning
huh is huge here okay where is 55 to 45
it's uh a 1 a 1 55 45 well we can't find
it anyway why did that get your
attention well I've got my attention
because this this may be the beginning
of or certainly an extension of rolling
back the the right to abortion that was
established in Roe vs. Wade which
appeared to be limited in the Supreme
Court's language but but in
is unlimited in practice and and the
Senate took an opportunity to to vote
against an egregious form of abortion
and I think we will see other other
restrictions coming out of this Congress
and this puts and this puts the lead
probe or ssin side in a box because they
don't ever want to talk about the
details of abortion yeah there was a
very strong piece that by women who
don't have gone this procedure in The
Times New York Times op-ed page about we
ago which I must had a strong effect on
me and she described what happened when
your baby has though it's quite well on
has in fact died inside you and in her
case she was told it wasn't possible to
induce it or remove it by cesarean
section for barest reasons that would do
with her own state of health that this
was the only way of ridding herself
actually of a fetus that was already
dead and she said also the procedure
isn't as scary and horrifying as in
someone has been made out the very lured
things we've been told about crushing
the skull with scissors and so forth on
I'm sure in fact the dead child could be
handed to her for a leave taking in
reasonable condition before him taken
away so I don't know I mean I certainly
would would ask anyone who wants to
think seriously and morally about this
to look look out that piece you you
walked in with this piece on your agenda
Christians against the welfare cuts are
arrested in the capital by Frank Klein's
and a barely notice counterpoint to the
budget battle 55 evangelical Christian
preachers and followers were arrested in
the Capitol Rotunda today as they sought
to speak up for the poor and confront
lawmakers with Biblical verses against
retreating from society's duty to help
the needy and here's a photograph by
Steve Crowley he'll tell you what struck
me about it was the it was the opening
sentence of its own page B 15 and the
event which it does describe the arrest
of all these clergy in the Rotunda is
described as a barely noticed event
which suits a very strong and bizarre a
way of opening a new story I mean that's
only true if the reporter says it's true
and I brought along with me from the
nation Ralph Nader's column on Media
Matters the
nation which has the neutrons doing this
again on November 24th he says the New
York Times published a page one story
about Somalian that explored why quote
an odd Harsha's fawn over Washington the
sound of advocacy groups that have been
unable to create much of a clamor
against the most drastic cuts in decades
even Ralph Nader points out excuse me
the reporter in all modesty left out a
significant explanation for this odd
hush
the New York Times itself I don't the
times kind of read this column because
here is one protest against the budget
cuts being reported in The Times on page
B 15 with the intro that the protest it
covers was as it says barely noticed so
I think it's some it was worthy of note
you know commas vitreous V as being self
confirming yes if a tree falls in the
forest on the Times doesn't hear it does
it make a sound at looking at the cover
of National Review can you explain this
it says National Review hits 40 can we
get a close-up of this
I see Newt Gingrich in a rush limbaugh
and Fidel Castro no no that's socialism
Oh huge mistake excuse me that's why I
should have kept my mouth shut
whatever who are the other people is it
the piano well you see to the left of
Rush Limbaugh is Genghis Khan at the
table there so we are all everyone
else's to the right of Genghis Khan
playing the piano is bach johann
sebastian who do you have that you've
got reagan dancing with Clare Boothe
Luce you have you going to water and yes
the subject of my book toasting each
other is that that's Barry Goldwater
then you go down here in the corner you
have any comment on this mr. Hitchens no
yet not yeah any we have heard that you
have a martyr with Uncle Sam you have
the Statue of Liberty lighting bill
buckley cigar and his sister Priscilla
Buckley next to him Socrates there is
mixing cocktail sugar that I think we
aired it should have been Aristotle
should have been Aristotle well the
nation which was founded in 1865
naturally congratulate Saul magazine's
the
last 40 years and I'm very pleased to
see that the people who the National
Review most admired when it started who
would Joe McCarthy and Francisco Franco
have neither of them made they didn't
show up they didn't yell out at me when
that they of course were given
invitations and seats at the head table
but they were unable to make it but
that's progress with kindness so we had
so we had to give their space to Bach
now we asked mr. Hitchens to describe
what this cover is all about that's the
cover of Vanity Fair that I think speaks
itself that's all about in the film and
good piece to inside piece by me about
the amazing fact that some on New Year's
Eve this year at the stroke of midnight
the baby boomers will turn 50 and I
think one of them will carry on turning
50 every we worked it out every 1.7
seconds for the rest of next year being
melancholy air for the boomers and I've
written a piece saying what a
disappointment the baby boom generation
has been to itself into others and mr.
Birk eyes are you right in the National
Review
about the baby boomer group - yes it's
right here it's called passing phase
well one at one of those baby boomers is
going to be President Clinton yes this
year 50 Jennifer yeah we had we had a
whole series of articles in there about
the detour of history from 1914 to 1991
we thought that the 20th century was had
not lasted a hundred years it was a
rather short century it began with World
War one and it ended with the collapse
of communism and this wasn't an original
insight with us Eric Hobsbawm and John
Luke Asif also thought of it so we had
various speculations on what this means
to come out of that and what I wrote
about is yes we may be coming out of it
but what what about those of us who were
born in the midst of it and how do we
how do we recover from the from the
limitations on our education that were
placed upon us by virtue of having been
born when we were that photo you saw are
those series of photos was from Vanity
Fair in your in your column we rarely
put on the Thurman on our cover in your
column we leave these serious matters to
be covered by Vanity Fair you bring up
you say this one of the most pointed
publishing phenomena of the last several
years was the seventy month presence on
the bestseller list of William Bennett's
the book of virtues who was buying that
three pound doorstop not kids clearly
its purchasers were adults many of them
baby boomers who bought it to read to
their kids
you weren't yet they they weren't they
also reading for themselves and he now
has the what the moral compass another
sequel and the moral compass for kids
and bringing that subject up for both of
you what's the fascination do you think
with the book of virtues I just had to
review the book of virtues for The Times
Literary Supplement I had no idea - I
was paid to read it how bad it is
why is it bad shallow and boring and how
poorly selected and how pompous there's
the for example though is just in a book
of virtues for American children there's
I think one page from the whole Mark
Twain and it's it's the boring bit where
Tom Sawyer paints the whitewash is
defense and yet there's about eight
pages from one of the Watergate burglars
about how he found God or one of the
Watergate burglars who did find God it's
absolute pabulum I think I don't believe
anyone has really read it unless they've
been paid to do so I'm sure it's been
bought with the best of intentions but
it's a huge disappointment for Kaiser
well the thing is it's filling a gap I
mean we had the reason it did so well is
because there's very little else out
there like it once upon a time there
were more Guffey's readers you know
which which everybody bought everybody
read in fact the conservative book club
has told me that their biggest selling
book has been McGuffey readers they just
took these hundred-year-old collections
of moral tales and reissued them and the
reason these things are so popular is
that the rest of the culture is not
providing it we're all doing uma Thurman
I like that I can't let that go I can't
let go of room with with a sec that men
who could this is why virtue fellowship
this is why batchi first was great
magazine you showed the cover once but
who is can't some
who is in the Thurmond I'm going to read
this and find out now do you follow me
say another word it's about my piece my
I don't take the quite the same line on
the baby boomers as does Richard though
I think the idea of the short 20th
century is a very interesting one and
I've also attempted to contemplate it
but whatever is you know what what are
we going to say I mean I'm a 49er myself
that's when I was born so it's not long
for me what are we going to say was our
great achievement will it really be true
that President Clinton is our typical
president I certainly hope not
describe him with sort of partly a
callow youth and partly a bit of a chin
pulling old bore already some of the
time what has been a great moral stand
what has been our great composure or
author I mean all just any of these
questions is to invite a terrible
feeling of disappointment I think that's
true can you tell us who oh my Thurman
is why she's an actress I saw her and
Harry and June before I walked out of it
why did you walk out it was boring
Richard Brookhiser of Rochester New York
and Christopher Hitchens of portsmouth
hampshire england you're living though
in new york city that's right and you're
living in washington DC and our call is
from martinez california good morning
good morning
how are you gentlemen good morning
morning what's on your mind this morning
well I always just thought I'd try and
get it through to mr. Hitchens and the
first time I dialed I got through I
don't even know what to say no because I
just woke up it's pretty early out here
Denise I know you and you woke I've
noticed how you feel by the way a couple
of quick questions are you going to come
out to the coast to a vlog your new book
which I'm do a reading here in the Bay
Area yes I am if I don't be in the
barrier of a Christmas I'm hoping to get
a reading what you organized okay I was
gonna say don't be too hard unless baby
boomers you know it's the we had a lot
of rate against us there but um I want
to wonder it seems to me that I don't
understand why with all this talk about
the liberal media why there isn't one
single left
network I mean I think
with all the resources of the left if it
was able to focus that's what we should
do
I've always thought that mr. Lam was the
Chief Whip and organizer of the left on
the air back collar because he's
committed to objectivity and as some
then it used to say only the truth is
revolutionary a collar that let me
anticipate that the Conservatives
calling will say that that's what those
networks are the the main commercial
networks that they are of the left would
you agree with that it wished the main
networks the commercial air they're not
they're not excused to being the left
there are cues to being liberal totally
different but even though even that
they're liberal is such a joke I mean
let's talk about who owns them gentlemen
I'll leave that to the to the
journalists here but uh where are you on
the political spectrum well I'm a
Christian anarchist myself if you're
going to characterize it is that
anything and henry adams and many others
I'm someone that believes that the
Christian Right is neither
I think it's Christian all right I think
it's right also I thought that's what
that's where she was the worst bumper
stickers I've seen this year as the
Christian Right is neither I would say
it's obviously both the you know the the
notion of having one's own network I
speak from across the spectrum to you it
often be muses people and I think it's a
it's a mirage
I mean I've sat in on discussions of why
don't conservatives by ABC there was a
period when it was in bad financial
shape or why don't we do this why don't
we do that and ultimately it's not worth
thinking about because even if you were
able to do it you'd you'd ghettoize
yourself and the best thing to do is to
you know as mr. Hitchens does as I try
to do just do your work and hope to do
it better than other people and get in
mainstream places beyond jet watch too
much TV Providence Rhode Island you're
next oh good morning hi a great job I
appreciate your service here welcome Oh
what amuses me is as follows when the
Reagan's get into office we had a
bombshell about some dishes a Hollywood
connection then we had a bombshell years
later about some dresses that Nancy
Reagan borrowed or something uh and now
we have the real juicy Hollywood scandal
that
oh how these left people and liberal
people would love to have I have had on
Reagan or anybody else was a
particularly Gingrich and I'm talking
about travelgate and mr. Tomasson and
that whole gang and with the White House
past and they moved in and they abused
seven career civil servants to get their
way and how it's not even being touched
or covered how it is the definitive
scandal and the definitive story about
this Clinton and his kind in power now
hop it would be Reagan it would be
absolutely farms away and I just think
that sooner or later
this will come out I myself in one of
the grassroots non-christian and I use
this is such a mole to keep about twenty
or thirty votes out of the Clinton
column although it's futile here in
Rhode Island I think this particular
story and the fact that is not being
covered is all the evidence I need that
there's a loathsome sickening liberal
bias in this country if this is Reagan
this is all we would have heard all
right thanks well look in defense of
liberal reporters I think one thing that
that saves Clinton is what used to be
called in discussions of nuclear
missiles fratricide you didn't want all
your nuclear missiles coming in at once
because they blow each other up and not
the target this was called fratricide it
was something to be avoided
the reason Clinton escapes time after
time is that there are so many scandals
associated with them and they all crowd
each other out and have the effect of
negating each other
so I think I think that's what keeps him
healthy ideas I have the impression that
senator D'Amato and his hearings are
reported all the time I mean I did
think that it's possible to say that
this door has been buried by any element
of the media probably the Washington
Times puts it on the front page more
often than the Washington Post but that
there at all it is every day and I mean
it seems to me also very clear that this
slightly Banana Republic way will make
that the very Banana Republic way which
mr. Clinton and his wife ran the state
of Arkansas was was imported by them to
some degree to Washington and and that
that's been found out and it's a
permanent boil on their back here is the
front page story today on whitewater in
the Western Times Hillary's mystery
phone call
apparently routed to McCarty let's go to
Santa Monica next go ahead please yes
good morning Brian
hi before I ask my question I just
wanted to mister Brookhiser
I am NOT going to have my usual morning
coffee because when I turn the TV on and
saw your outfit I thought gee this is a
wake up right here really nice hey let
me trying to wake myself up let me show
you you all don't know how hard this is
to be here at seven o'clock in the
morning let me show you another one of
mr. Brooke Heiser's outfits this was in
the New York Times what what is this
Mike this is how I dress in New York
where is this photo that's my house and
and is is that on all by my living room
that's your living room wait that was in
the New York Times in February yes to
get any response out of that photo well
every that this was an article on Young
Conservatives and this was done the last
time it could possibly I could possibly
be in it because I was just before I
turned 40 so those days are now all gone
but everybody else in the article didn't
like their pictures I think that's one
of the best pictures that's ever been
taken to me now that we have Santa
Monica wide awake
go ahead yes mr. book guys I wanted to
ask you in your in your the National
Review loose an article there was an
article about a deal that I have not
read it a deal that Clinton had made
with the Russians hold on just said can
you hear her we've lost oh I see you're
you're just one of those morning go for
it there yeah we've got all these let me
just plug him in so hey now start again
please
okay now I can hear you alright there
was supposed to have been an article in
your in the in the National Review about
the deal some kind of a deal that the
Clinton had made with the Russians yes
that's in the yeah that's in the issue
that will be coming out today or
tomorrow or Monday it's it's the current
issue the one after this one and our
senior editor Peter Rodman who actually
supports going into Bosnia the the
magazine does not support the Clinton
plan but he does but he has found he has
found out that the administration has
assured the Russians that if they will
cooperate with this Bosnian operation
not make trouble that NATO expansion
into Central Europe will be put on hold
indefinitely presumably now Warren
Christopher has already been asked about
this he's denied it of course that's
what he would do I don't see what's
what's so startling about it I mean it
is a scoop but but the this
administration has been dragging its
heels on NATO expansion for years now
and they've just decided to apparently
formalize this in the interests of
making their Bosnia scheme go color are
you going to get into that anymore well
we we've broken the story we've got it
in the magazine we've already been
talking about it on on talk shows in
anticipation and we're hoping to elicit
some some reaction from the
administration I understand that speaker
Gingrich has written or will write a
letter to the White House saying what
gives here here's a fax from Doug Henry
of Hanover New Hampshire I guess he
moved there because up in the corner
used to behavioral it says what does
Chris you don't like that do you and
somebody come home as my mother a mother
Cory Chris no I person whether I'd never
let anyone do it I'll it's a waste of a
nice name what does Christopher think of
his intellectual fairy tale utopia
collapsing and Frank didn't understand
the grammar of the question as far as I
know the 1789 revolution is still going
strong
next call we go to Jacksonville Florida
go ahead please oh yes I just had a
couple questions regarding the Bosnia
and the reporting on that I haven't seen
really addressed and I'm curious how
they feel about the understanding of
military operations by the clinton
administration into that nation for
example in somalia with the the problem
with the Bangladeshis and now with our
troops going into bosnia there's a large
problem there with snipers and mine
we're sending in a heavy force there but
I don't see the understanding on the
Clinton administration regarding exactly
what they're going to do in there and
how they're going to deal with that
threat ie a sniper takes a shot in
sniper alley and how are you going to
return fire with heavy armor and tanks I
know Hillary was down there to send us
boys off and talk to the wise but I'm
under saying will she be there at the
airport when they come in casualties -
well look IIIi think the Clinton
administration believes that they have
an agreement that all the three sides
support and if that is the case then
presumably well they believe that that
there wouldn't be sniping or that there
wouldn't be this problem I think they're
being they're being too optimistic with
this and I also think their notion of
what the goal of the mission would be is
is a little hazy which is the problem if
you have a goal and if it's absolutely
necessary to you you go in whether
they're sniping or whatever it is but
I'm not sure that that that applies here
I was just in Bosnia of note for the
first time I think this will sound odd
perhaps to the caller but the main part
is going to be the fan of the winter is
coming on if it wasn't for that I think
we would hear more of what we heard from
the very first soldiers who went the
other day they are trans party who
basically said the whole place was a
very pleasant surprise to them as
beautiful the people are very nice it's
a very civilized country which all of
which is absolutely true and you'd never
you'd never know from most of the
reporting people are really really fed
up
the war even those who feel that it's
not a just agreement Dayton are just
glad of the chance to have a breathing
space they'll be a huge penalty
reflected by Bosnian site in my opinion
or anyone who tries to restart this war
and the doctrine of overwhelming force
promulgated softened by General Howe
does seem to have been observed in this
case I mean 20,000 Americans to say
nothing of huge contingent the other
NATO kind is an enormous number of
soldiers for a country for a country the
size of Ohio and I don't it's true that
a lot of Mines lying around but I didn't
I think we're very bold person indeed to
who tried to take on by sniper fire or
any other method of warfare such a force
so I've no doubt lived to have these
words questioned against me but it seems
to me odd that some I can't press better
not make a guess about the politics of
the caller very odd that that there are
still people who want to vote for the
enormous new military appropriations
that the Republican majority has imposed
upon us but never want the United States
to use force anywhere I don't know why I
think we we should have it one way or
the other later on in this program we're
going to talk with Philip noise who is
the director of the movie clear and
present danger and the subject will be
Hollywood in Washington and politician
also senator joseph Lieberman what do
you think of Bill Bennett and Sam Nunn
and trying to find the story here in
Times this morning
and with joseph Lieberman going after
these talk shows advertisers well look
if you don't like something this is a
boycott this is very libertarian way to
to register your disapproval now it's
not entirely so because of course
Lieberman and none are senators they're
not they're not your average private
citizen but but certainly of anyone a
free markets here has to say well if you
if you don't like this stuff guys this
is the way to do it in this story and I
can't find it
well it seems here's got the wrong
advert
well they took on Mars bars well they
started when they first cut this the the
commercial
let's see continuing a crusade they
started six weeks ago to take the try
shot of daytime television talk shows
bennett Lieberman done yesterday named
names unveiling a television commercial
that aired three companies to stop
advertising their products on the racier
programs one of those that they had to
recut it because they they took on three
musketeers of the Mars company and the
Mars company convinced them that they'd
stop spending money look you know but
you know Brian my wife has been on a
couple of these shows because she's a
psychoanalyst which happened genie safer
she has a book coming out in February
actually but she's been on a couple of
these shows because they want you know
the expert to come on at the end and
kind of tie everything up and it is an
unsettling experience to be on them
because and of course they all very they
do very there is a spectrum but
especially as you get towards the bottom
there's there's a there's a kind of
schizophrenia to them because on the one
hand they are very a judgmental and and
moralistic about the people that they
have honest guests you know I slept with
my father all that kind of thing but
they are also being titillating I mean
they they are they are luridly exposing
this stuff for their own enjoyment and
and then I guess the final thing is the
condescension and the contempt that is
implicit in these things directed
towards their guests and even towards
the audience to a certain degree so it's
complicated Oprah Winfrey Winfrey has
been kind of exonerated by this group as
being okay
what's your reaction to this disc Oprah
Winfrey was once fantastically nice to
my son when she when I took him to the
Oscars party that - she forgives over
here so I would have word said against
your fat ass oh and as a reward for good
behavior I'm taking my son to see the
Money Train this weekend just which I
wasn't planning to see until senator
Dole told me I shouldn't go yeah that
was that one of the really things it
started since he thinks of the crime on
the New York subway is created by motion
pictures I think really think he am mr.
Bennett with
I felt you much time on that house
you're gonna how old is your son now
he's living and you're taking him to see
the money track yeah this weekend yep
as a reward for good behavior those who
have never heard about the Money Train
what is it well I don't know so that I
know senator Dole says I shouldn't go
and see it because if it wasn't for the
motion picture industry there wouldn't
be crime on the New York subways I know
that's wrong so just to in case anyone
has been so foolish as to listen to dull
and not go I'm going to go put my
dollars where my mouth is Del Mar
California thanks for waiting yes I
think this there's connection between
the Americans not being honest history
or literature the past 30 years and
someone like planning getting elected in
1992 my main concern about him was his
history of young man he was not anti-war
he actually supported a communist
Vietnam and I was very concerned he'd be
a very activist informed policy and he
has turned out to be just that where did
you see him actively support a communist
Vietnam I think that was his activity in
Europe I think you organize
demonstrations I was a constituent at
that time the campuses were organized
lots of money flowed in to the United
States in fact it was one of the Front's
of the war where our campus any
organized demonstrations what did for a
communist government in Vietnam just
well they said it was anti-war but was
basically to help to help North Vietnam
win the war and that did help North
Vietnam in the war when they turn public
opinion against it and now I'm concerned
the here is this renegade president
sending our young people to Bosnia to
support a very partition here in code
Ireland where there was unjust partition
in the 20s and he against that what you
should be and he supporting this unjust
partition which rewards the aggressors
in Belgrade and he's using our young
people to stabilize it
thanks mr. Prakash well I I guess the
thought I have is that Americans there's
a reason why so many generals have ended
up being president and some of them have
been excellent some of them have been
terrible but that's the only profession
outside politics that Americans
return to four presidents and that is
because war making and war leading is an
important is a crucial matter and when
politicians lack that experience it can
get them into trouble during their
administration let me show you this
because it goes with what mr. Burke
Arthur said about generals this is at
the bottom of Washington wire today Ron
Schafer's column on Friday in the Wall
Street Journal
Powell's popularity soars even higher
after he for goes a presidential run was
61% of Americans expressing positive
feelings about him well I have actually
I have probably the biggest piece that's
going to be done on the Paul campaign
coming out in March in Forbes fYI I went
on the whole Colin Powell book tour I've
seen the bookstores of America and I saw
I saw the people that that story refers
to the people who admire this man he
went on the whole : pal doctor I missed
I missed eight cities but that means I
went to 18 I let me come back this in a
second because I want to get mr.
Hitchens reaction to all this um will to
the lady who called in who I think is
confused I could just assure you ma'am
I was I was at the same university as
mr. Clinton during that time
Oxford yeah I can tell you that there
was no money from outside for our
movement against the war I can also tell
you that mr. Clinton was no extremist if
he had been an extremist I would have
known him I was the speaker at most of
his rallies he was a mere moderate
attender he was considered very well
behaved by the people who were really
genuinely Merson D opposed the wars I
was still one of the proudest moments of
my life was to oppose that war mr.
Clinton you must have noticed ever since
has been has been trying to apologize
for his very mild opposition as much as
he counted on every hospital cajon it's
almost the only good position he's ever
taken and he can't wait to run away from
it we just asked her quickly because we
got a caller wedding and I want to ask
you more about the tour but if the
Bosnian thing leads to casualties
American casualties and more involvement
can the Republicans have it both ways
when it's all over can they say we
oppose this we never want to go in there
and be legitimate about it
but I don't know what was wrong we had a
caller earlier saying what they're
really doing yeah they're having an
arrest we have a play where they would
ask me whether you agree with the caller
that suggested Republicans won of both
ways they're not trying to stop the
troops from going over there but they're
saying they're supporting the military
and then when if it does turn sour they
can come back and say well we had to
support the military but we didn't want
to stop having it both ways i mean the
president has the responsibility the
president is the commander in chief a de
facto it's evolved that the president
controls our foreign policy in these
ways and he would have done this he had
the power and he would have done this
with or without Congress the program's
question is while the is their
positioning going on on the other side
of the aisle other words are they trying
to create a an impression that they can
say we told you so if it doesn't work I
think I think in a ham-handed way rather
hesitant way they are trying to do that
well at work I guess that's my question
is it no because I think actually the
American voters who obviously not keen
on Bosnia are not totally indifferent
about I think this I think that's a bad
conscience there's an awareness that the
United States could have done more
earlier about it there's a feeling that
it's not it's not a bad cause and nor is
it a hopeless adventure that it's a sort
of prudent risk that a superpower can
decently take at a but but it's also not
the case that that all the people who
are opposed to this are against doing
anything in Bosnia I mean National
Review has been urging for two or three
years that we do things in Bosnia we
just we think that this is not the right
thing
we hope it works we're doubtful that it
will call from North Little Rock
Arkansas thank you for waiting
good morning Brian hi Pam uh I was just
a few things I would like to say uh
everybody keeps talking about mr.
Clinton the thing about mr. Clinton he's
mister clearly done everything about
Arkansas that Arkansas is cat Arkansas
didn't wasn't doing nothing before mr.
Clinton what's better down there now
everything the living for the pool and
that's one of the reasons why that the
Republican bunch don't like mr. Klain
because he was
out to help the pool and the black
especially if he do if he wasn't if he
hadn't have done had to had the record
of that he would have been in the better
president they would have done
everything in my power to keep him in
but because he helped the pool that's
why they got all the scandals Oney Oh
everything they come up with I mean you
think people said you know mr. Clinton
helped before so we're gonna get him on
the scandals well the same way to done
JFK they kill JFK because he had the
deal of being nice to the black people
who Snell whose day be this the bunch
that goes around and puts out all of
them the all of these lies is you if you
want to say it all right thanks great I
guess that's me right killed him then
neither one of you agree with the
gentleman's know I've been talkin so I
mean I took mr. Clinton at his word when
he said come on come on down you
remember that at the convention of the
Arkansas miracles are very great friend
of the rich you know and so I mean these
are all the donors who we've since been
finding about but this man says he's a
friend of the poor well I have would
said how different impression that
mister mister clinton was look what i
can saw it doesn't have a civil rights
statute yeah I think it's the almost
daily state that doesn't it's a
right-to-work state very hard to join
the union it's extremely backward in all
those respects the income disparities
are colossal but there is a great deal
of wealth there that's true and mister
Clinton's and that knows almost everyone
who's involved in in holding the purse
strings mr. Burke I sort of governor
that he was um what was it 28 days on
the tour I was there 18 I did 18 days 18
days I mean you physically went to every
all these books on all the press
conferences would you stand around and
watch it or what well what you did there
was always a press conference about 10
minutes before each one of these things
and then you looked at the line and you
talked to people on the line and you see
you you saw what they had to say and I
think general Powell was a screen on
which a lot of Americans were projecting
their desires and and this will end if
he does ultimately run for president
because he's going to have to take
positions he's going to have to take
issues he'd begun to do that but he
would do more and more and he'd get his
own personality and it would be harder
to make him this white screen how many
of of the percentage of the people that
showed up for autographs were white uh
it was about 8 to 1 ratio
and that was pretty consistent some
places Milwaukee actually had the
highest percentage of black people on
the line and what did did you and the
general become close friends No
did you talk at all other than I asked
him questions and the press conferences
what is your you know what's your take
on him as a I mean you like him or not
or he's he's a solid guy in a lot of
ways personally temperamentally
I think the great the great lack that he
has and this would be the great
distinction between him and the first
general president the subject of my book
is that general Powell has no ideas and
sees no need to have any and and Aziz
and on ideological map did you do this
because you had this book coming out no
I did it because the editor of Forbes
fYI called me up and said what are you
doing with the next month of your time
would you like to do this and I said in
a minute would you like to have done
that no I would not know I was I'm
really disappointed choice thinking I
might get a Colin Powell free TV
pregnant but what this would be one of
the benefits of him finally having
gained to tell us that he's not going to
run out so relieved I actually won some
money on it too I thought also now now
not every conversation that I have will
be poisoned by speculation about this
complete nonentity I mean not interested
in the sense that Richard describes as
having no ideas and no convictions and I
would add no principles but not
unfortunately nonentity in his in his
record and he's been he was able to play
an undignified part in
the world Vietnam and helping to cover
over me like mask I was able to play a
disgraceful role in the invasion of
Panama he lied directly to Congress
about his role in the iran-contra
scandal and I'd like I'd like to think
that he and he decided to Bauer because
he would have finally had to answer
these questions if if he'd run but the
merciful press made sure that he was
never asked them while he was different
next week as we've said we're going to
have our satellite truck and cameras in
Ohio all week every morning on the show
we're going to focus on one of eight men
who were present in the United States
and the interesting thing about this
discussion is that a lot of them were
generals William Henry Harrison Benjamin
Harrison Rutherford B Hayes James
Garfield
maybe maybe McKenna McKinley was an
officer I think it is a captain or a
mayor I think he was a major but the
idea for that next week is a start
Sunday is that you can compare what was
going on in those different presidencies
it's one state it's a way for us to
concentrate in one area and see if the
issue is ever discussing then have any
relevance to what's going on now or
maybe better put is there anything new
in present-day politics San Francisco
thanks for waiting
good morning hi to you and your area
died guests morning our Chronicle has
Bosnia the budget Newt Gingrich and the
continuing tawdry tale of a trial in San
Francisco Federal District Court which
the a policewoman police officer has
sued the police chief in San Francisco
for sexual harassment by the way of
President Harding died in San Francisco
in 1923 at the Palace Hotel on a
campaign trip just put questions Brian
yeah only you can answer maybe Chris one
is the background music that played
during quorum calls and votes it gives
the classical music to be appreciated if
you could identify you know what some of
the music is also there's a lot of great
American classical music they've pretty
good
faye and george gershwin you might think
about that and the other is in Prime
Minister's question time the first
question is always question number one
from the Conservatives and the Prime
Minister major always says that he had
meetings in the morning and will have
meetings in the afternoon etc etc then
subsequently there will be popped up a
question question number four or number
six to which the Prime Minister always
refers to saying I refer the Honourable
gentleman to the answer I gave some
moments before and could they all be the
same question what does it all mean Oh
take the answer off the air thanks I
think that's a great way to conduct this
program
mr. Brookhiser question number three and
you know really because um I can't I
can't
enlike me on this I think the questions
are all printed on the order paper so
most people they have to be in fact but
the question was usually phrased
deceptively the the person says has the
Prime Minister any plans to visit say
Manchester if that's where he represents
that's where his constituency is it if
the Prime Minister says yes he has then
the supplementary we will if he came to
Manchester this is what he would find
out people thought about his policies
and so on they tried to set traps in
this way while asking pro forma
questions so the door the gorge is to
say I've heard that one before and I've
also answered it so we'll we'll take
that question and elaborate on let's
never do that you only happen in the
moment you know wait Lincoln during the
Civil War was approached by a delegation
of senators and and it was suggested to
him that they have a question time and
the president have to come to the hill
and answer questions and he took the
Dodger from pleading national security
and said he wouldn't do it but I still
think it would be a very good idea well
you know what we stopped doing that it
actually happened when a treaty with the
Creek Indians was being proposed in
Washington's first administration you
know the Constitution says with the
advice and consent of the Senate
treaties are negotiated well we have the
consent of the Senate but we have never
had a president going to the Senate to
ask for its advice because we did it
once and this was with a treaty with the
Creek Indians
Washington actually went to the Senate
with his plans what he was going to have
his negotiators say and it was such a
such a botch first of all the windows
were open no one could hear it as it was
being read so finally they got the
windows closed then a discussion ensued
people asked for more papers Washington
lost his temper a bit he says this
defeats my whole purpose of coming here
he left weekend past he came back on a
Monday he was fine everything everything
went but he was heard to say as he left
he would be damned before he came there
again if he can plug his book one time
suddenly you can plug it is a picture
here I want to ask you about right here
why did you include this picture of a
deceased Robert Maxwell with mother
Theresa praying the rosary well the book
is about all this all the shady
connections of mother's reason and all
the things that you should know about
her and earned her connections with
basically with either right-wing
dictatorships or with corrupt right-wing
businessmen okay you call him attention
of corner stir kidding was the model of
the mink Lincoln Savings and Loan is the
model of a corrupt right-wing
businessman is currently doing 10 years
for it he gave her a million and a
quarter dollars of stolen money which
she's yet to return there the court in
Los Angeles has asked her for the money
sure she won't give it back he in his
turn got from her crucifix on the use of
a private jet sorry he gave her the
private Jack she gave him the crucifix
and many many indulgences and pieces of
support Maxwell used her for a fund
raising pyramid scheme to become one of
his newspapers of while he was raiding
its pension fund so that I just think
the pictures so hilarious of her sitting
there with her rosary while he's on the
phone
apparently drumming up custom here's
what the cover of the book looks like
how much is this car sputtering there
you have me guide now I ought to know an
idea it doesn't say and it doesn't say
Jones Island South Carolina go ahead
please hello Jones Island you're on the
air there you go hello hello good
morning Brian
how you doing just fine sir um good
morning gentlemen
and my question is to Christopher
Higgins
and I am for Hitchens I'm sorry I always
get so nervous I'm so glad you're back
to the subject of the book concerning
Mother Teresa I occurred a brief report
last week that she had entered into
prayer for aids children babies that are
born dying of AIDS you know she wants a
cure and then there is this lady I
believe she's in New York and I think
her name is they call her mother Jones
she takes a lot of these abandoned
babies from the hospital and funds I
suppose I'm not too sure she takes care
of them what I would like to know is
what is your opinion as a society how
should what what obligations would we
have should we have on taking care of
babies that are born dying and I'll take
my answer off the air thank you well
because I company that this woman by the
way is able to take dying or AIDS
suffering babies from a hospital you
know what you look after them but it's I
suppose it's possible if the story went
went past my bad I think that we're in a
very grave moment just now that's part
of why I wanted to bring up the arrest
affairs judgment of the rotunda
yesterday where it seems that that oh
the society Lisa as expressed by
Congress and through the wish of the
president is going to say that it
doesn't want any longer to shoulder the
burden of responsibility for all
American children I'd like to have they
going to cut them off the bottom of the
roll that the two of you what do you
think of I talked to Christopher
Hitchens for years about is the price
yes twelve twelve ninety five snip at
the price what do you think of him being
I don't know if the word is obsessed but
you certainly have written and talked a
lot about Mother Teresa
over the last couple of years I don't
think it's obsession thank you you have
a no look I mean you you you you have a
subject in your your taking it on and I
haven't read the book so I'm not going
to comment I suspect
I suspect it's a little harsher than I
would be at least but I wouldn't if
you've been doing this for 40 years and
I might then we might be getting into
obsession but some couple years it keeps
on coming up this this week the the
nastiest thing that Michael Mandelbaum
and his co-authors a critique of
Clinton's foreign policy confined to say
about it is that it's the foreign policy
of mother Teresa in other words they by
which they they mean or think they mean
that it's it's naive to the point of
being too charitable of course what I
argue about mother Teresa is that she's
the reverse of that in the reports of
the Verte on divorce in Ireland recently
for example where Ireland was until last
week the only country in Europe where
divorce was illegal finally in
referendum the Irish people voted
against the advice of the church and
voted to legalize divorce mother trees
are interesting very heavily on the
other side which is the sort of thing
she tends to do she's always involving
himself in political disputes in other
countries she's basically a political
rather than charge will figure the
reports that mention this mentioned it
in a bewildered way as if even mother
Teresa got involved rather than as if
that's just what you'd expect her to do
and so as long as that impression is so
widespread I suppose I have to keep on
trying to correct it i speaking of
bedfellows and connections and always
stuff this is just a little piece in the
National Journal and I want to ask you
to explain what this means there's a art
piece here with its President Lincoln
there with it with a camera and there's
no face on it but it says okay what's
dude really up to and and this is in the
National Journal to bomb the page came
out today it says in an odd bedfellows
alliance conservative political activist
and economic consultant Jude Winooski is
backing the candidacy of Democratic
Representative Robert G Torricelli
for a New Jersey Senate seat menisci and
the reason I ask this is you say you're
writing from Forbes FYI and juban s Keys
been involved with Steve Forbes and
presidential Kansas League Winooski who
recently hosted a dinner at a midtown
Manhattan restaurant at which his
wealthy Wall Street clients met the
candidate said he told tower telling
quote if there weren't an active lively
kradic party the Republican Party would
continue right until it ran into Adolf
Hitler unquote
a toward Hitler menisci elaborated would
be toward a government that's quote no
compassion ellipses all individualism
what's Jude Winooski up to no compassion
is certainly a mild description of
government that's like Adolf Hitler look
I read the way the world works when it
came out
he's book his book in the late 70s I
thought it was very important I'll
always acknowledge my debt to it but
Jude Winooski told me during the last
election cycle that Ross Perot was going
to win an overwhelming majority in the
electoral college unless the leaders of
the world world finance had him
assassinated I'll say anymore Las Vegas
thanks for waiting again sorry to keep
you folks on the line go ahead please
okay uh I'm reading the Las Vegas
review-journal and this been I have it
right here no you don't yes yes I do I
thought I did sorry I must have left it
in the restroom I'm two things is the
boss when iam age six hundred million
dollars to real rebuild the country and
that will run into billions of dollars
and then I go down and I see I'm a next
Californian I moved out of there six
years ago because you couldn't even move
in the traffic but they have an
immigrant influx there and they've got
three and a half million legal
immigrants and two and a half million
illegals now they're all applying for
citizenship so they can vote and they
say that if they had voted then that one
eighty seven the proposition wouldn't
have passed well Here I am living in
Nevada and I have to pay taxes for those
people even though I don't vote in
California I don't live there and I vote
from Nevada I'm still paying for these
illegal immigrants you're also less
living in the fastest growing city in
America do you know that
oh yes that the traffic is getting just
as tremendous if it wasn't California
when I left
what say either one of your reaction to
our callers initial comment about
Emirates
well look America I don't think you can
Dogma ties on this to to have a position
that applies in all cases and in fact
American immigration policy or American
immigration has varied over the last 200
years we've had periods when very few
immigrants were coming in and then we've
had periods when a lot have come in it's
gone in cycles it hasn't been a steady
thing now up until this century these
cycles were controlled by events in
Europe mostly wars famines you had a
famine you got people you had Wars often
that prevented people from coming they
were controlled by external events but
as we've gotten into the 20th century a
travel to America has become easy enough
and cheap enough so that we no longer
have this external regulator on it and
if we want to maintain the policy policy
that we've had over two centuries and
which is worked
that is to say cyclical you have
ingestion and then you have digestion if
we want that we have to do that
ourselves by our own laws and I think
it's time for a period of digestion
Richard Brookhiser are you still writing
a column for the observe yes I am are
you still writing for Time magazine ah
occasionally are you still writing for
the talk of the town and the New Yorker
ah probably not since Tina Brown in The
New Yorker no in the New York Observer
well that's that's going against that's
going against Goliath only David like
weapons say you're a you're out of there
I guess so uh and you'd still with the
National Review yes since 1977 and a
graduate of Yale yes and are you still
support and marijuana uh yes yes I'm
focusing on medical marijuana I mean I
have opinions on all the drug laws but
since I had came years ago and pursue
chemotherapy and marijuana is very
effective against the nausea and I think
it's insane that people are unable to
get it for medical
purposes what kind did you have Arowana
or cancer testicular cancer and are you
clear yes and we saw you during that
period you just you went ahead on on
television and you wore the Ben you know
that but your hair and you lose your
hair uh Quentin crisp said an
existentialist to someone who shaves his
head when he's going bald so you know I
was told my hair was gonna fall out so I
said I'm not gonna wait around for it to
fall out I'm just gonna shave it off
was that hard during that period to
appear publicly and no no you got used
to it you pick your band down as well
you look kind of cool and mr. Hitchens
you be right for Vanity Fair and the
nation and have your book and other
things that's it for now
is that it now promoting the book mmm
yes is plenty and as your brother Peter
gone back home he's gone back home so
the Hitchens dog-and-pony show is over
from you miss him
yes I'd have to say I did huh but all
that many intelligent conservatives in
Washington that we can afford to lose
one like my brother we have time for one
last call Macon Georgia go ahead please
hi yes a couple calls ago a gentleman
was talking about the travelgate
so-called travelgate any invention that
Reagan that was been Reagan it had been
impressive been all over him that's all
ooh Lucas Reagan was the Teflon
president everything slid off of it I
mean here probably the most corrupt
cabinet that in the history of this
country had four or five guys indicted
and and people would be truthful really
truthful Clinton's doing a better job
than Bush did I mean Clinton's doing a
pretty good job as a president and did
you vote for him oh yeah vote upon and
on what basis do you say he's doing a
better job well the economy is better uh
his foreign policy is not that bad
Haiti's a lot better off and it was I
mean the Caribbean
I mean we know we know weaker I mean
he's the one to do just a good job but I
mean he's doing a better job in Bush mr.
Hitchens is that true
I'm it's it's true for Haiti I must say
but I people who think of them politics
in terms of lesser evil I think have to
accept all the logical and probable
consequences of what they believe and I
don't believe any Republic
administration would dare do what the
Clinton administration is doing well
welfare especially as it affects
children I think they would have been so
afraid of what the Democrats would have
said and may be done about it there's
some there's some jobs so dirty only a
Democratic administration can do them
and that is part of the lesser evil
calculus unfortunately it's the thing
that people usually leave out but your
what everything you said about Reagan is
of course completely true breck eisner
well the Regan right the reason Reagan
had Teflon was not that he was charming
that he gave a good speech it was that
he had ideas and beliefs that were
consistent over 30 or 40 years people
knew where he stood a lot of people
disliked it like the caller presumably a
majority liked it and so he kept the
head he kept forging ahead and people
were willing to cut him a lot of slack
this book founding father rediscovering
George Washington by Richard Brookhiser
on the bookshelves in the stores in
February 22nd imagine to remember day in
American history and this book is out
there now it's a mother Teresa the
missionary position did you name this
book by the way yes 1295 in the
bookstores either that'll sacred cow and
I thought say Luke I would be in bad
taste Christopher Hitchens and Richard
Brookhiser thank you well that you will
pause here for a moment